[موسيقى]
مساء الخير سؤال بسيط لماذا يعتقد اليهود
والاسرائيليون ان جيشهم هو اكثر جيوش
العالم نبلا واخلاقا هم بيعتقدوا كده اه
والله العظيم مش بيعتقدوا ان جيشهم واحد
من اكثر جيوش العالم نبلا واخلاقا اكثر
جيوش العالم نبلا واخلاقا لماذا يشعر
الاسرائيليون لماذا يشعر اليهود وهم بشرا
في نهايه المطاف بالرضا عن انفسهم
بالتعالي الاخلاقي ويتحدثون عن القيم
اليهوديه الاخلاقيه الاستثنائيه في رفعتها
رغم تورطهم في ارتكاب كل انواع الجرائم
على الاقل تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني
النوع ده من الاسئله حاول يجاوب عنها صحفي
اسرائيلي اسمه جدعون ليفي من هو جدعون
ليفي ولماذا اتحدث عنه اليوم انا بتحدث
عنه اليوم بمناسبه التطورات الساخنه في
الاراضي المحتله وبقطع النظر عن تفاصيلها
وهل ستخفض ام تتصاعد في الايام المقبله هي
ليست الا دوره من دورات العنف الاسرائيلي
تجاه الفلسطينيين وهدفها دائما واحد
اصرار اسرائيلي على قمع اي محاوله مهما
كانت بسيطه من الجانب الفلسطيني لمقاومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لارضهم
من هو جدعون ليفي ليفي صحفي اسرائيلي ولد
في تل ابيب في السبعينات من عمره بيقول
انه خدم في جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي لكنه
فعل ما هو اسوا ما يعني انه يعتبر خدمته
في جيش الدفاع سيئه لكن ما هو اسوا انه
انخرط في العمل السياسي مع بعض السياسه
الاسرائيليين في شبابه ومنهم شيمون وهو
واحد من اهم الشخصيات الاسرائيليه في
تاريخ دوله الاحتلال عمل معه في السبعينات
في نهايه السبعينات وبدايه الثمانينيات
لكن تغيرت حياه جدعون ليفي حين زار مصادفه
الاراضي المحتله في نهايه الثمانينيات
ووقتها راى بام عينه حجم الانتهاكات الغير
انسانيه من الجيش التي انضم اليه وكان
يفخر به على ارض الواقع
وقرص الثلاثين او الاربعين سنه الماضيه من
حياته في كشف فضائح الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وجرائم جيشه او ما يسمى بجيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي في معرض الاجابه عن السؤالين
اللي انا طرحتهم في اول الحلقه هو كان من
القضايا اللي شغلاه كيف يشعر الاسرائيلي
بالرضا عن كل هذه التجاوزات لماذا يشعر
بالفخر بجيشه المتورط في كل انواع الجرائم
ما هو كون الجيش محتل هذه جريمه عشان تكرس
الاحتلال انت بتستخدم القوه المفرطه
واحيانا القوه المميته انت بتقوم بهدم
المنازل انت بتقوم بقتل الاطفال انت بتقوم
يعني القتل خارج نطاق القانون يعني
التصفيه الجسديه في الشارع بدون احكام
قانونيه فانت متورط في كل الجرائم
الاخلاقيه ازاي بقى مع كل ده انت بتشعر
بالرضا طبعا السؤال ده مطروح لان هو
اسرائيل كان عنده هذا الت صور هو شايف كيف
يرى الاسرائيليون انفسهم كيف يشعرون
بالرضا كيف يتباهون بتفوقهم الاخلاقي على
جيرانهم توصل بعد فتره طويله من الدراسه
الى انه السبب الاساسي للفخر بجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والزهو الاخلاقي
للاسرائيليين نابع من سيطره ثلاث افكار
رئيسيه على العقل الاسرائيلي والعقل
اليهودي الفكره الاولى
هو قناعتهم بانهم شعب الله المختار في حد
طبعا ممكن يقول لي طب هو جاب ايه من عنده
ما كلنا عارفين ان هم يعتقدوا انهم شعب
الله المختار لا ده كلام ليس بديهي لانه
الفكره دي كانت شائعه لدينا نحن العرب منذ
سنوات طويله وكان يتم السخريه منها من
المثقفين الغربيين ومن المثقفين اليهود
وظهرت طائفه وجيل جديد من المثقفين العرب
بيسخر من الفكره دي ويقولوا انه ان في
تيار ديني او تيار غير ديني بيصم اليهود
بما ليس فيهم وان اليهود ليسوا هكذا
يفكرون ودول ناس مثقفين وسوفسكيت والى
اخره يعني هو بيقول لا انا خبرتي معرفتي
بالشعب الاسرائيلي انه مستقر في اذهنهم
فعلا انهم شعب الله المختار وهم شعب الله
المختار لاسباب دينيه وغير دينيه اسباب
دينيه يعني مبنيه على تفسيرهم لايات مثل
الايه الشهيره اللي موجوده في صفره
التثنيه لان ك شعب مقدس مقدس لربه لانك
شعب مقدس للرب الهك وقد اختارك الرب لكي
تكون له شعبا خاصا فوق جميع الشعوب الذين
على وجه الارض
واليهودي العادي بيشكر الله في صلواته كل
يوم لانه اختاره شعبا صفيا له للسبب ده بس
كمان الاسباب غير دينيه يعني اليهودي غير
المتدين يعتقد انه شعب الله المختار لانه
حاله استثنائيه يعني يعتقد اليهود العادي
انه افضل من باقي شعوب العالم انه حاله
خاصه وان ال15 مليون يهودي في العالم افضل
من باقي البشر اللي هم حوالي 8 مليار نسبا
ليه 15 مليون دول عدد البشر الذين عرفوا
انفسهم بانهم يهود في استطلاع اجريه في
2020 والعدد لم يزد كثيرا في 2023 قبل
وطبعا اذا كنت تشعر بانك شعب الله المختار
يترتب عليه ان ما ينطبق على الاخرين لا
ينطبق عليك وبالتالي ليس غريبا ان اليهود
لا يشعر بتناقض ان يريد مثلا ان يطبق
القانون الدولي لكن هذا القانون الدولي لا
يجب ان ينطبق عليه طيب قبل ما يغادر
النقطه دي اذكركم طبعا للانصاف ان قناعه
الكثير من اليهود انهم شعب الله المختار
ليست قاصره على اليهود بل موجوده لدى كثير
من اصحاب الديانات الاخرى
لكنها لكن اليهود اخذوها الى ابعد مدن
ولذلك كان المرحوم المفكر المصري الشهير
الدكتور عبد الوهاب المسيري كان بيقول
لليهود شعب الله المختار ولا المسيحيون
ملح الارض ونور العالم ولا المسلمون خير
امه اخرجت للناس بالاطلاق في كل زمان
ومكان ومع اي فعل او وضع او ظرف كلام مش
منطقي طبعا
الفكره الثانيه اللي مسيطره على العقل
اليهودي والعقل الاسرائيلي انهم ضحيه
ليه ضحيه وازاي ضحيه قصه طويله جدا وتحتجن
تحتاج دراسات كثيره وتحتاج ان احنا نتكلم
عنها في حلقات كتيره لكن اختصارها وفهمها
ليس صعبا الفكره المسيطره على اليهود انهم
ملاحقون من شعوب الارض الاخرى على مدار
التاريخ وانهم مستهدفون وانهم مضطهدون في
كل مكان بيقولوا الكلام ده وبيرصدوا له
وقائع واحداث على مر مئات والاف السنين
وبيزيدوا على ذلك حتى لما هربنا واردنا ان
ننجو بانفسنا من اضطهاد الشعوب الاخرى
ولذنا بمنطقه صغيره في داخل العالم العربي
يعني اللي هم بيقولوا انها كانت ارضهم
طوال الوقت لم نسلم من اذى ملايين من
العرب والمسلمين الذين يريدون الفتك بنا
والقضاء علينا
النوع ده من الخطاب كان بيلقى اذان صاغيه
ومبني على جزء من المنطق عند تاسيس دوله
الاحتلال في الاربعينات
والستينات الى اخره السبعينات الثمانينات
انما مات هذا الخطاب غريب جدا بعد ان
تغيرت كل الامور واصبحت اسرائيل صاحبه
اكبر واهم اقتصاد او يعني اغنى اقتصاد في
المنطقه
اقوى جيش في المنطقه لديه كل انواع اسلحه
الدمار الشامل وعدد رؤوس نوويه قادر على
تدمير كل العالم العربي وغير العالم
العربي
فانك تشعر بانك انت الضحيه بينما انت الذي
تمارس هذا الاحتلال فكره عجيبه غريبه
ولذلك يدعون ليفي بيقول هي دوله عجيبه
غريبه لانه سبق مش هي تجربه الاحتلال
الاولى في في التاريخ بيحمل لنا تجارب
احتلال بعضها طبعا اطول كثيرا من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لفلسطين بعضها اكثر قسوه
ووحشيه لكن لم يحدث ابدا في التاريخ ان
قدم محتل نفسه على انه ضحيه الا مع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اللي بيقول انا
المحتل وانا الضحيه وزي ما قلت لحضراتكم
شعورهم بانهم ضحيه عميق في العقليه
اليهوديه انا شفت مقاله مكتوبه لصايمينا
رودوفيتش الفيلسوف الامريكي اليهودي سنه
1948 عنوان هذا ايفر داينج بيبل وخلاصتها
بيقول انه اليهود مسكونين بفكره الخوف من
ان ينتهوا من ان يتم تد وكل جيل كان بياتي
بيعتقد انه سوف يكون اخر جيل في هذا الشعب
لان الشعوب اخرى سوف تقضي عليه عموما دي
قصه طويله لكن اللي يهمني فيها هنا انه
جزء منها مستقر عن قناعه عن صدق في عقول
البعض وجزء منها مفتعل لتبرير ممارساتهم
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
جلدمير دي برضو كانت رئيسه وزراء اسرائيل
وتولت السلطه يعني حتى اثناء حرب اكتوبر
1973 واللي هي خسارتها للحرب وضعت نهايه
لمستقبلها السياسي او لحياتها السياسيه
كانت لها كلمه شهيره بتقول فيها
بعدما حدث لليهود في الهولوكوست على ايدي
هتلر يحق لليهود ان يفعله ما شاؤوا
ثانيا اللي بتسيطر على العقل اليهودي
وتمرر له افعاله هو
نزع الطابع الانساني على الفلسطينيين يعني
مش شيطنه الفلسطينيين مش اعتبار
الفلسطينيين على انهم
مجرمين على انهم معتدين على انهم رافدين
للسلام لا
اعتبرهم غير ادمين في الاساس طب ازاي
يعتبرهم غير ادمين هم بيقولوا ان هم مش
ادمين لا ما بيقولوش كده ولكن هو بيصر على
صوره نمطيه للفلسطيني خلاصتها ان
الفلسطيني شخص عنيف وغير رشيد
غير منطقي يرغب في ممارسه العنف وهذا
العنف ليس سببه رغبه من الفلسطيني في
مقاومه احتلال غير قانوني وغير شرعي وغير
سليم ولكن رغبه في ممارسه العنف من اجل
العنف خصوصا ضد اليهود وانهم ناس يقدسون
فكره الموت وبالتالي لا يمكن التعامل معهم
الا باستخدام القوه المفرطه او القوه
المميته
الفكره دي فكره شائعه يعني اللي درس دراما
او اللي درس ادب او اللي بيدرس سينما
يلاحظ ان دايما في شخصيات فلات شخصيات كده
مسطحه وشخصيات مركبه في الروايه اللي
بتدرسها او في الفيلم اللي بتشوفه الشخصيه
المركبه عاده انت بتتعاطف معها لانه اللي
بيكتب الفيلم اللي بيخرجه اللي بيكتب
الروايه بيخليك تعيش مع هذا الشخص فتتعاطف
معه مهما ارتكب من جرائم ان كان لصا ان
كان قاتلا ان كان جندي في جيش بيحتل ارض
غيره الشخصيات الفلات انت لما بتتعاطفش
معي انت بتشوف منها جانب واحد كتير من
الافلام الامريكيه مثلا يعجب لك الجند
الامريكي اللي بيقتل بدم بارد عراقيين او
افغان او صوماليين او ناس من امريكا
اللاتينيه بس انت كمشاهد بتقع ضحيه هذا
التسطيح انت بتحب البطل ده بتتعاطف معه
بتتفهمه بس انت بتشوف ناس ملثمه بتحاول ان
تقتل الجندي الامريكي
وبتشعر احيانا بالرضا ان هو بينجح في
اللحظات الاخيره ان يضع نهايه لحياتهم يضع
نهايه لهؤلاء الملثمين الشخصيات السطحيه
ديت
لحياتهم البائسه
والفلسطينيين بيعطوهم هذا يعني بيقوي هذه
الفكره بالتركيز كثيرا على فكره نحو شعب
نحب الموتى كما يحبونهم الحياه هم بياخدوا
العباره ديت ويؤكدوا بها فكره هم يرغبون
طوال الوقت في القتل والموت ونحن مضطرون
الى قتلهم حتى نعيش في كلمه شهيره قالتها
برده مره
قالت فيها
يمكننا ان نغفر للعرب قتل اطفالنا لكن لا
يمكننا ان نغفر لهم اجبارنا على قتل
اطفالهم لن يتحقق السلام مع العرب الا اذا
احبوا اولادهم اكثر من كراهيتهم لنا البعض
شكك انه جولد قالت الكلام ده رغم انه
موجود في مواقع يهوديه مهمه
واسرائيليه مهمه لكن حتى لو انه شخص اخر
هو قال هذا الكلام دقه الكود او الاستشهاد
لكل دمائير ليس مهما لانه هذه القناعه
مستقره في اذهان اليهود وهو ده اللي
بيقولهولنا جدعون
وبيقول بالنص كلنا نؤمن باننا افضل وانهم
ادنى هم اليهود
ضد الفلسطينيين طبعا كلنا نؤمن باننا افضل
وانهم ادنى حتى لو لم نعترف بذلك نرضع هذه
الفكره من صدور امهاتنا نحن مختلفون نحن
افضل هم اسوا انهم ليسوا بشرا مثلنا لقد
ولدوا ليقتلوا ويريدون قتلنا وطبعا يترتب
على ذلك نحن لازم نقتلهم وبيقول ان هذه
القناعه المستقره في عقول اليهود هو ما
يفسر المشاهد اليوميه من قتل وطعن واحيانا
اعدام خارج نطاق القانون انك تقتل واحد في
الشارع بدون محاكمه
من جانب الاسرائيليين للفلسطينيين وبيقول
ان انا شاهدته كثيرا وشاهد غيري واحنا شو
بنشوف على شاشات التلفزيون على كل حال
يعني مش محتاجين ان هو ياكل لنا المعلومه
انه فلسطيني يقتل في الطريق احيانا لان
كان فيما يدعو لذلك من جانب الجندي مش
شايف مع مسدس شايف معه سكين احيانا بدون
اي ما يحمل اي شيء للاشتباه فيه احيانا
نتيجه مشاده ويقتل الفلسطيني بدون اي
محاكمه وتسقط جثته وهو بيحكي بقى بشكل
درامي جدا بيقول ان المشهد ده متكرر
واعتاد عليه الاسرائيلي وهو لا يشعر
بالتعاطف معه ولا ياس عليه رغم ان هذا
الاسرائيلي بين قوسين ده هو بيقول هم بشر
وبعضهم خير جدا ويسرع لتقديم العمل الخيري
في اي مكان في العالم والتبرع لمن يحتاج
الى اخره يعني
وبيقول انه اللي بيحصل بعد قتل هذا
الفلسطيني يتم تغطيه جثته احيانا لا يتم
تغطيه الجثمان انه الناس
الفضوليين بيبصوا له كده احيانا بفضول
يتاملوا المشهد وبعضهم ممكن بدون تعاطف
وبعضهم ممكن يلتقط صوره تذكاريه مع سيلفي
اما الجنود ففي العاده بينظروا الى هذه
الجثه كما ينظر الصائد ابو الصياد الى
جثمان الطريق بعد ان سقط على الارض
بيقولوا انه في مره كان يعني يشاهد على
احد المعابر وانه في سياره فلسطينيه وده
مشهد متكرر كثيرا سياره اسعاف فلسطينيه
بتحمل جرحى ومرضى لكن الحاجز اوقفها
للتلات ساعات بيقول انا بعد اكثر من ساعه
وانا بنتظر يعني اراقب سلوك الجنود هم
هيفرجوا عن هذه السياره امتى فنزلت وبسال
سائق السياره الاسعاف الفلسطيني فقال له
انا هكذا يجري معنا يطلب منا او نترك لمده
ساعه على الاقل قبل ان نسال الى اين نتوجه
وقبل ان يسمح لنا بالعبور فبقول انا توجهت
للجنود وانا حاولت تجنب ذلك كثيرا لكن
المشهد استفزني وحاولت اتجنب ليه لانه ده
دايما بيؤدي الى مشاده لا تحمد عقباها مع
الجنود
الاسرائيليين وسالت السؤال التالي هل لو
كان منفي سياره الاسعاف ابوك هل كنت سوف
تتركه لاكثر من ساعه يموت قبل ان تسمح له
بالعبور نقول بمجرد تشبيهي
لابائهم بفلسطينيين استشاطوا غضبا انا
ارتكبت جريمه كبيره ازاي اجرا على تشبيه
ابائهم بفلسطينيين نحن اعلى هم ادنى نحن
افضل ام اسوا هم لا يصووا بشرا وطبعا لما
انت بتوصف واحد على انه صبحي ومن اقل من
البشر
شيء بيريحك في التعامل معه بيريح ضميرك في
انك ترتكب معاه اي نوع من انواع الجريمه
اصلا بيحلك من الحديث عن اي حقوق للانسان
ما هو مفيش مجال لحقوق الانسان اذا كنت من
تتعامل معهم ليس انسانا ده زومبي ده شخص
عنيف ده شخص قاتل بطبيعته بيقول مره انا
سالت ده هو سال يهود براك اللي كان
كان رئيس الوزراء وزيرا للدفاع شخصيه
مشهوره ايضا ومهمه في تاريخ دوله الاحتلال
وكان مرشحا لمنصب رئيس وزراء اسرائيل قبل
2010 فبيسالوا السؤال التالي في حوار
الصحفي معه ماذا لو كنت فلسطينيا ماذا لو
كنت قد ولدت فلست
كان عنده من الشجاعه ان يعطيني الاجابه
الوحيده الصادقه وقال له لو كنت ولدت
فلسطينيا كنت سوف التحق بالمنظمات
الارهابيه افتح قوسين يعني المنظمات
المقاومه لكن الاسرائيلي يسميها ارهابيه
وبيقول له ماذا كنت تتوقع مني لو كنت قد
ولدت فلسطينيا هل اصبح شاعرا ان اصبح عازف
بيانو قطعا كنت سوف احمل السلاح ضد
الاسرائيليين وبيقول ان هذا السؤال وهذه
الاجابه فتحت علينا ابواب الجحيم ونقد
كبير جدا وسائل الاعلام ويعني جهات
اسرائيليه مختلفه طب ليه الثوره على
السؤال وعلى الاجابه السؤال اللي استدرك
شخصيه عامه زي اهوت براك واجابه اهوت براك
لانه الشعب الاسرائيلي يعيشوا في حاله
انكار والتعبير لي جدعون ليفي حاله انكار
يعني كثير من الاسرائيليين اما لا يعرف ما
يجري من جانب جيشهم تجاه الفلسطينيين او
اختار الا يعرف او انه يعرف ولا يهتم ولا
يوجد امل من وجهه نظره في اي تغيير من
جانب الاسرائيليين ابدا ليه لا يوجد اي
دافع للتغيير او امل في التغيير اولا
توفقا لي انه الحياه رغده جدا في اسرائيل
بلد الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها اكتر من
400 مليار دولار في يعني الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي سنويا يعني تقريبا
قد الاقتصاد المصري مع الفارق الضخم جدا
في عدد السكان
مساعدات بلا حساب من جانب الولايات
المتحده ولكن ليس من الولايات المتحده
وحدها رغم هذا الثراء بتحصل على مساعدات
مستمره على كل الصعد
اثنين انه الاعلام الاسرائيلي اللي بيصفه
ان هو اعلام ينتمي فعلا لدوله ديمقراطيه
قادر على محاسبه المسؤولين وكشف كل جرائم
جرائمهم وفسادهم الا فيما يتعلق بالحقوق
الفلسطينيه فهو اعلام مدلس وموجه لا يذكر
ابدا الحقيقه الا نادرا
تلاته ليس لديه دافع او ضغوط خارجيه لانه
اسرائيل مرتبطه بصداقه فاسده كما يصفها مع
اقوى دوله في العالم وهي الولايات المتحده
وهذه الدوله تبارك كل ما تفعله اسرائيل
وليس لديها ابدا الرغبه في ممارسه ضغوط
حقيقيه على الاسرائيليين لتغيير سلوكهم
الامر اللي بيضر من وجهه نظره باسرائيل
لانها ممكن تكون مكان اكثر امانا ويضر
بالولايات المتحده اللي تورطت في مخالفه
كل القوانين الدوليه او كل الاعراف
الانسانيه
لاسباب يعني هو بيعتبرها ملغزه عليها
علامات استفهام في دفاعها عن ابنتها
اسرائيل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
كل اللي قاله ده كل اللي قاله جدعون ليفين
هو محاوله لتفسير ليه قناعه الاسرائيليين
بان جيشهم هو اكثر جيوش العالم دبلا
واخلاقا وليهم عندهم هذا الشعور بالرضا
الاخلاقي عن انفسهم لكن ما لم يذكروا
واللي ممكن نضيفه كبند رابع وهو امر خطير
جدا يمكن اخطر من الاسباب التلاته اللي
قدمها جدعون ليفي وانا وضع لحضراتكم روابط
كثير مما قالوا هذا اليهودي الشريف
السبب رابعه السبب الرابع اخطر من الاسباب
التلاته يمكن في تقديري انه جدعون ليفي
بيقول انه الاسباب اللي بتبرر هذا الموقف
تجاه الفلسطينيين هو انهم يعتقدون انهم
شعب الله المختار انه
الفلسطينيين ليسوا ادمين وانهم شعب عنيف
وغير عقلاني وغير رشيد وانهم الضحيه وانهم
شعب ضحيه يعني ضحيه في كل الاحوال انما في
ناس ذهبوا ابعد من ذلك هو اعتقادهم ان
الفلسطيني بالاضافه الى كل ما ذكر جدعون
ليفي هم يقاتلون او يحاربون حربا خاسره
ويطالبون بما ليس لهم انتم بتحاربوا على
ايه انتم عاوزين
بتحاربوا على اساس تستعيدوا اراضيكم هذه
ليست اراضيكم انتم لستم موجودين اصلا يعني
في قطاع يعني انتقلنا من حاله الانكار الى
مرحله اعلى مرحله التزييف وده اللي كان
بيقول عليه المفكر الفلسطيني الامريكي
الشهير ادوارد سعيد حاولوا كثيرا اقناعنا
اننا لسنا موجودين اصلا
الفكره دي مستقره وحاول اليهود تاصيلها
بكل السبل الاكاديميه ولا غير اكاديميه
انا كنت بكلمكم على جولد مائير جولد مائير
قالت تكرارا ومرارا كلام خطير جدا كرره
قاله قبلها ناس وبعدها ناس خلاصتها انه
انتم بتقولوا العرب غارقين في اسطوره اننا
اخرجناهم من اراضيهم هذا كلام فارغ
لم يكن الامر كما لو كان في فلسطين شعب
الفلسطيني فاجئنا وطردناهم واخذنا بلادهم
منهم لم يكونوا موجودين اصلا مين اللي ما
كانوش موجودين الشعب الفلسطيني كما يتصوره
العرب والمسلمون ايوه كان في فلسطينيين بس
مين الفلسطينيين انا الفلسطينيه مين اللي
بتقول جماهير قالت ايام بلاستينين لكن
انتم مين انا اللي اتولدت هنا انتم كنتم
مجموعه من البدو جاءت عاشت لفتره زمنيه
اكثر بكثير من عمر الشعب اليهودي وانتم
موجودين بس لكن لكن ما كانش فيه فلسطين
وفلسطينيين غيرنا
فلسطينيين الفكره دي مش قاصره على جولد
مائير ده انت عندك حتى هذه اللحظه
الرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بيروي التاريخ
الاسرائيلي على النحو التالي كنا نحن
اليهود منذ اكثر من 2000 سنه في هذه البقع
من الارض ثم جاء العرب جاء المسلمون
اخرجون من هذه الارض حاولنا العوده فقالوا
لنا نحن محتلون بينما نحن نحاول محاوله
استعاده اراضينا التي عشنا فيها على مدار
قرون ذا تصور التصور ده برضو مش قاصر على
الشاشه الاسرائيليين ده انت عندك ناس من
الطيار اليميني الامريكي ومن الشخصيات
النافذه الامريكيه عندها هذه القناعه انت
عندك نيود ريتش كان بيقول ان تعبير الشعب
ده كان رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي شخصيه
جمهوريه مهمه بيقول ان تعبير الشعب
اليهودي ده تعبير مخترع بلا اي معنى عندك
على سبيل المثال شيلدن اديلسين
اديلسين ده اللي هو الملياردير اليهودي
اللي كان يعني قبل ان يتوفى مؤخرا وكان
كريما جدا في تبرعاته لليه اسرائيل واللي
دعم كثيرا قرارات ترامب المحابيه لاسرائيل
ايضا كان بيقول هذا الكلام الشعب
تعبير الشعب الفلسطيني تعبير فيك زائف
ومخترع لم يكن حقيقيا على العموم
لكل الاسباب اللي انا ذكرتها اسباب
يدعون ليفي الثلاث والسبب الرابع اللي انا
اضفته من عندي عدم قناعتهم ان كان في شعب
فلسطيني من الاساس
بيترتب عليه الاتي انا ما نفعله نحن
الاسرائيليين او اليهود نفعله دفاعا عن
النفس ولذلك جيشهم اسمه جيش الدفاعي
الاسرائيلي لا مجال للحديث عن حقوق
الانسان لان الفلسطينيين ليسوا بشرا زومبي
يترتب على اعتبار الاول والثاني ايمان
الاسرائيليين ان جيشهم هو اكثر جيوش
العالم نبلا واخلاقا لانه جيش شعب الله
المختار يقاتل همجا يحبون الموت ويقاتلون
من اجل قضيه خاسره
امرهم غريب اولاد العم اشكركم والى لقاء
اخر باذن الله